I love people who go all out.
And the actress Taraji P. Henson
is certainly one of those people.
She told InStyle that during lockdown,
she built herself a full beauty salon at home
complete with a real cash register.
That's the part, by the way,
that was the detail I love too.
She says, it's her own little world
and it makes her feel good.
And it's stocked with her TPH by Taraji haircare line.
And she hosts her Instagram series
from the salon sharing tips on how to nourish and protect
your hair and scalp.
Thoughts?
I think it's really fun that she put a salon
in her house, the cashier, the register.
It makes me laugh.
I hope she takes her own personal check,
but then I thought, what would I put in my house?
Like if I was to really take a swing like that.
What would you do?
Thought about it,
It would be a movie theater with a soda fountain machine.
You know what I mean?
Mm, I love fountain soda.
I, Taraji, I'm actually on board with this kind of cuckoo.
I like this about you.
And I'd like to come to your salon.
It's cute.
And you know, this COVID, it's been tough on everybody
and we couldn't go to the salon.
So put one in your house.
And you know, we talked about during the whole pandemic
the rise in comfy casual style.
So if you're dreading shedding those sweats,
well I have great news for you.
Refinery 29 reports parachute pants are back.
Hey, Drew, what time is it?
Hammertime.
Yup, remember these bits?
An update on the old hammer pants we all know and we love
Drew, am I gonna see you in hammer pants?
No. All I know is that my inner thighs
don't need that material rubbing together
making a loud sound like no, thank you.
And parachute.
It doesn't feel good next to the skin.
It's like, why do you want that material on your body?
I don't know, I just thought you'd find like some fun.
And then the nostalgic nature of it.
But ehh.
Do you like them?
Are you going to wear them?
I didn't say I liked them or that I was gonna wear them
but I like that people are wearing them.
All right next.
If you're looking for a way to feel more awake and energized
in the morning, you might want to try the RISE-UP method.
Rossi, I saw what this is, everybody get ready.
I was really intrigued.
I have to say it kind of was really revelatory.
So HuffPost reports that RISE-UP
was developed by sleep scientists and studies show
it can make your mornings feel less groggy.
Okay. It's an acronym.
R is for resist the urge for the snooze button.
I is for increase your physical activity
in the first hour, you are awake, Rossi?
Yeah, I do this.
I get up.
I'm a, I'm a, I'm a morning person.
I'm like Belle in Beauty and the Beast,
good day, bonjour, I say hi.
It's annoying.
Smelling baked bread and whole nines.
In my basket.
S is for shower or get that cold water
onto your face and hands.
I agree with that.
A little hmm hmm hmm.
Okay, E is for expose yourself to sunlight.
Wait for it, to sunlight.
(laughter)
Uh huh.
U is for upbeat music.
Yes. It would be fun to put on a little Donna Summer.
Get going.
I need to get on this RISE-UP program.
P is for phone a friend.
That surprises me.
Me too.
Maybe they're on Who Wants to be a Millionaire.
(laughs)
I used to love that show.
It's like so major.
Well, if you're looking for a good way
to get that blood flowing in the morning
there's a new way to make fitness fun.
When you think it's time to work out, it's like eye roll.
Well now enjoy.
Apartment Therapy reports, fitness dice
will game-ify your workout.
Game-ify it.
It comes with dice
that you roll out to get a different workout
every single day.
So I have some here, six of the dice show you
different fitness moves that only require your body weight
no special weights or bands needed.
And the seventh dice tells you how many reps to do.
Got it?
So one will say a number, one will say the exercise to do.
Let's throw it out.
It goes like this.
Oh, Drew, we're gonna try it.
We're going to do 10, 10 squats.
All right.
The last time we did squats here on the news desk,
I pulled my back.
'Cause I'm, speaking of seniors.
We can do this Drew.
This is our exercise for the day.
(applause)
All right, 10 squats.
10 squats.
That's this, ready?
We'll do it together.
Where, where do your hands go like this?
(audience chanting)
I don't know.
Squat, one, wait, one. what one,
You know, with squats
my trainer Katrina Rinne always says
that you're supposed to put like the weight in your heels
Uh huh, four.
I have to say this.
I really am into this.
I stopped counting.
Okay. I did too.
But they kind of look like sex Kama Sutra dice also.
Well that was my question.
If they came in funsies ones, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pick another one.
Okay. 15 reps of what is he doing?
Oh, let's do a different one.
(laughing)
He's like, literally all it did was this.
Hold on this one's good.
Try this one.
Okay.
15 of this.
All right.
(energetic music)